zum zweiten Mal nach 2015 steht
Deutschland vor einer gewaltigen
Herausforderung erneut muss das Land
innerhalb kurzer Zeit viele Flüchtlinge
aufnehmen unter anderem mehr als eine
Million aus der Ukraine
obwohl bereits jetzt mehr Menschen in
Deutschland 2022 Schutz erhielten als in
jedem anderen Jahr
könnten noch Hunderttausende je nach
Verlauf des Krieges in den nächsten
Wochen kommen
die flüchtlingsjahre 2015/16 haben
Deutschland enorm viel abgefordert jetzt
wieder Start und Bevölkerung haben große
Aufgaben zu lösen es geht um Geld ein
Flüchtling pro Monat in der Turnhalle
kostet ungefähr 2000 Euro es geht um
neue Ideen für Wohnraum privates wohnen
ist ein Sprungbrett in die Gesellschaft
eine richtige
integrationsbeschleuniger und um den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
[Musik]
wir sind alle gleich und wir leben
einfach füreinander und miteinander
ZF Zoom fragt haben wir aus 2015 gelernt
[Musik]
Ende vergangenen Jahres
Innenministerkonferenz in München mit
Bundesministerin Nancy fäser das
drängendste Thema sind Flüchtlinge seit
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg waren es noch nie
so viele Länder und Kommunen schlagen
Alarm viele können keine weiteren mehr
aufnehmen
haben Sie konkrete zusätzliche Maßnahmen
zusagen können die Kommunen sind in
einer sehr angespannten Lage deswegen
habe ich ja in meinem Haus einen
flüchtlingsgipfel auch veranstaltet dort
hatten wir ja nochmal zusätzliche
Liegenschaften angeboten nur wenige
Wochen nach dem flüchtlingsgipfel war ja
doch schon wieder alles voll es gibt
Landkreise die Aufnahme Stopps verhängen
immer wieder ja und wir haben kriegen
mitten in Europa und dann passiert das
was in Städten wie Leipzig jetzt schon
passiert ist das Zeltstädte in entstehen
und der Bund hilft natürlich sehr stark
mit Geld wir haben jetzt gerade noch mal
dreieinhalb Milliarden für dieses Jahr
und für nächstes Jahr zur Verfügung
gestellt Geld das dringend benötigt wird
die Zahlen machen das Ausmaß deutlich
mit gut
722.000 Erstanträgen war 2016 der
Höchststand der Asylsuchenden im
vergangenen Jahr waren es fast 218.000
die meisten aus Syrien Afghanistan und
der Türkei
dazu kamen aber mehr als eine Million
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine und das sind
nur die die sich registrieren ließen im
Gegensatz zu den anderen Flüchtlingen
müssen sie keinen Asylantrag stellen was
braucht es um die hohen
Flüchtlingszahlen zu bewältigen
der ehemalige Flughafen Tegel die
meisten der Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine kommen in der Hauptstadt an im
Dezember waren es im Schnitt 300
Schutzsuchende täglich die sich hier im
ankunftszentrum registrieren ließen auf
den Landebahnen werden Leichtbauhallen
als Notunterkünfte errichtet eine
Herausforderung die geldorganisation und
Arbeitskraft erfordert im ehemaligen
Terminal treffe ich Migrationsforscher
Gerald Knaus er berät die
Bundesregierung beim Thema
Flüchtlingspolitik wie geht Deutschland
damit um schaffen wir das diesmal also
ich glaube was sehr klar ist ist dass
das ein ein Härtetest nicht nur für die
Verwaltung auf allen Ebenen sondern auch
für die deutsche Gesellschaft ist wie
wir ihn in Jahrzehnten nicht erlebt
haben denn die Leute unterzubringen ist
das eine sie zu betreuen ist das zweite
und es ist auch klar dass kein Staat der
Welt darauf vorbereitet ist auch
Deutschland nicht
so viele Menschen in kurzer Zeit
aufzunehmen
Rückblick die Registrierung 2015
tagelanges warten vor dem zuständigen
Amt so ist es jetzt nicht mehr
was wir hier in Tegel sehen diese
Aufnahmezentren das nicht Bilder
entstehen wie 2015 damals auch in Berlin
weil man weiß dass diese Bilder auch zu
Angst und Sorgen in der Bevölkerung
führen ich glaube das ist eine wichtige
Lehre damit kein Gefühl von Chaos
entsteht
kein Chaos aber die Unterbringung
schafft Probleme eigentlich ist Tegel
nur als ankunftszentrum gedacht zwei bis
drei Nächte Transit sozusagen dann
geht's weiter weil Wohnungen Mangelware
sind werden aus den paar Nächten oft
mehrere Wochen dafür dass die
geflüchteten nicht alle in den
ankunftszentren hängen bleiben soll ein
ausgeklügeltes System sorgen
Asylbewerber und registrierte Ukraine
die keinen Wohnraum haben werden nach
dem sogenannten Königsteiner Schlüssel
auf die Bundesländer verteilt
[Musik]
Nordrhein-Westfalen liegt mit gut 21
Prozent ganz vorn gefolgt von Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg die drei Länder tragen
den Löwenanteil die Aufnahmequote
richtet sich nach Bevölkerungszahl und
Steuereinnahmen und wird jedes Jahr neu
berechnet
[Musik]
in Thüringen machen im Dezember mehrere
Städte Druck auf die Landesregierung sie
fordern mehr Geld zur Anmietung neuer
Unterkünfte Erfurt ruft eine
Aufnahmesperre aus
in der Stadt sind zu diesem Zeitpunkt 5
Schulturnhallen belegt Oberbürgermeister
Andreas Bausewein zeigt mir eine davon
sie sehen es natürlich
53 Menschen untergebracht denn der Halle
ein bisschen abgehangen Privatsphäre ist
hier nicht viel hallo die meisten kommen
aus der Ukraine seit acht Monaten fallen
Sportunterricht und Vereinssport aus es
war ja schon 2015/16 so gab es denn in
den sieben Jahren dazwischen keine
Möglichkeiten andere Lösungen zu finden
die gemeinsam Unterkünften sind
rappelvoll Notunterkünfte die fünf
Turnhallen bis auf die letzten Platz
gefüllt und neue Räumlichkeiten zu
schaffen das das dauert Monate und Jahre
weitere Turnhallen will der
Oberbürgermeister nicht belegen auch
wegen der hohen Kosten nein Flüchtlingen
pro Monat in der Turnhalle kostet
ungefähr 2000 Euro
ja also sie müssen Bewachung die ganze
Versorgung kostet 1/200
die ganze soziale Betreuung und die
Bewachung und und die Versorgung und
vieles mehr das ist in in Wohnungen
einfacher und kostengünstiger sind sie
vorbereitet auf noch mehr die
Möglichkeit erschöpft deshalb die
Aufnahmesperre in Erfurt wie schwierig
es ist so eine Situation zu managen
zeigte sich 2015 damals sollten die
Kommunen schnell neue Unterkünfte finden
auf drängendes Landes das dafür
Zuschüsse zahlen wollte Erfurt mietete
diesen leerstehenden Baumarkt an für 5
Jahre
die Halle wurde nie genutzt denn es
kamen weniger Flüchtlinge als erwartet
für eine andere Nutzung fehlte der Stadt
die Genehmigung insgesamt neun Millionen
Euro Miete eine Fehlinvestition von
Steuergeldern
wie viele Flüchtlinge kommen weiß
niemand ein Problem nicht nur für Erfurt
Migrationsforscher Professor Hannes
schaman sagt wir müssen auch in Zukunft
mit schwankenden Flüchtlingszahlen
rechnen ich glaube wir müssen da ein
bisschen Umdenken eine
Risikolebensversicherung liest man auch
nicht ab um sie ausgezahlt zu bekommen
sondern man hofft dass man sie nie
braucht und ähnlich ist es hier mit der
mit der Vorhalten von
unterbringungsplätzen wenn wir sie ad
hoc immer neu aufbauen müssen dann ist
das viel teurer als wenn wir über die
Zeit hinweg etwas zahlen das heißt
Mietoptionen aushandeln bevor es brennt
und extra angemietete Großobjekte auch
für andere Zwecke nutzen wenn sie nicht
für Flüchtlinge gebraucht werden
[Musik]
weil solche Lösungen immer noch fehlen
nehmen viele Kommunen in Thüringen keine
Flüchtlinge mehr auf auch deshalb ist
die Erstaufnahmeeinrichtung des Landes
in Suhl seit Monaten übervoll
eigentlich sind hier nur 800 Bewohner
vorgesehen bei unserem Besuch sind es
rund 1.200 drehen dürfen wir hier nicht
wegen der angespannten Situation sei
eine Begleitung unseres Teams nicht
möglich außerdem bestehe
Infektionsgefahr
uns zugespieltes Material belegt
Berichte von Hilfsorganisationen und
ehrenamtlichen vor Ort dichtes Gedränge
schroffe Sicherheitsleute verdreckt der
Sanitäranlagen
für Reinhard huthopf vom evangelischen
Migrationsdienst Thüringen sind diese
Zustände unerträglich seit Jahren drängt
er intern auf Verbesserungen vergeblich
jetzt hat er genug und geht an die
Öffentlichkeit das gesamte Gelände
machten verwahrlosten und verdreckten
Eindruck es ist komplett überbelegt die
Verwaltungsabläufe sind darauf gar nicht
eingerichtet und ein großes Problem ist
das hier teilweise Leute zu uns in die
Beratungsstelle kommen die hatten noch
keine erste Untersuchung
die medizinische Erstuntersuchung sollte
sofort nach Ankunft stattfinden damit
sich keine Infektionskrankheiten
ausbreiten doch es dauert oft Wochen es
ist so ein ganzer Berg an einen
Missständen und das ist natürlich
peinlich auch für unsere
Verwaltungsbehörden
seit neun Jahren gibt es die Einrichtung
eigentlich genug Zeit um Strukturen zu
schaffen die einen reibungslosen Ablauf
gewährleisten
ein weiteres Beispiel dieser Arzt aus
Syrien er musste sechs Wochen darauf
warten seinen Pass wieder zu bekommen er
will weiter in die Niederlande wo sein
Asylverfahren läuft doch er saß in Suhl
fest weil die Verwaltungsbehörde seine
Papiere nicht wiederfand
nicht aufwindbare Dokumente verspätete
medizinische Untersuchungen keine
Beschwerdemöglichkeit wir konfrontieren
den zuständigen Minister mit unseren
Recherchen
das ist sicherlich eine Darstellung die
sozusagen alle Probleme die in den
letzten Monaten auch tatsächlich gar
keinen Zweifel daran auch aufgetreten
sind zusammen nimmt also die Zustände
dort stellen die sie zufrieden nein
überhaupt nicht warum ist es denn so
schwierig warum können sie da nichts
machen als migrationsminister wenn sich
die ankunftszahl fast verzehnfacht dass
wir da natürlich auch ein Stau
insbesondere bei den Erstuntersuchungen
dort für die geflüchteten die
Asylbegehren haben das ist richtig da
ist auch ein Minister nicht glücklich
mit
wenige Tage nach unserem Interview
musste der Minister seinen Stuhl räumen
auf Druck seiner eigenen Partei die
Grünen zu zögerlich zu wenig erreicht in
der Migrationspolitik
es ist ein Versäumnis der
Landesregierung noch sind für die
Erstaufnahme in Suhl zwei Ministerien
zuständig und eine Behörde erst jetzt
sollen die Zuständigkeiten
zusammengefasst werden in einem
Landesamt für Migration
in Konstanz am Bodensee ist man da
weiter die Behörden haben die Zeit seit
2015 genutzt Netzwerke geschaffen
Zuständigkeiten verändert neue
Strukturen aufgebaut aber weil diesmal
sehr schnell sehr viele Flüchtlinge
ankamen müssen auch hier wieder
Turnhallen belegt werden wie diese
Kreissporthalle in Singen acht Jahre
später mache ich mir ein Bild vor Ort
was hat sich verändert damals wohnten
hier vor allem männliche Asylsuchende
verschiedenster Nationalitäten jetzt
sind hier nur ukrainische Flüchtlinge
untergebracht meist Frauen mit Kindern
es läuft diesmal besser denn nach dem
Flüchtlingsansturm 2015/16 wurde ein
eigenes Amt für Migration und
Integration geschaffen Leiterin ist
Monika Brumm damals wurde das Essen
fertig angeliefert heute gehören sogar
Töpfe zur Erstausstattung
also das einer der Lerneffekte aus 2015
zwei 16 eben auch dass es kochen einfach
eine ganz wichtige Beschäftigung auch
ist für die Menschen und deswegen sind
wir sehr froh dass wir an den meisten
kreissportalen bis auf einer die
Möglichkeit haben dass die Menschen sich
das Essen selber zubereiten können
klopfen wir mal hier an hallo hallo
herzlich willkommen dürfen wir
reinkommen
guten Tag ich heiße Bärbel
und ich heiße Lena Jelena Lena und ihr
Sohn Christian tin sind seit Mitte
August hier sie kommen aus der stark
umkämpften Region saporisha und haben
seit den ersten Kriegstagen Todesängste
durchlebt mein erster Gedanke hier war
ich kann endlich ruhig schlafen ich kann
mich ausruhen und ich bin mit meinem
Kind in Sicherheit
anfangs waren sie zu viert in dieser
Parzelle eine Person konnte schon
weiterziehen jetzt lebt Lena mit ihrem
Sohn und einem fremden Mann hier auf 15
Quadratmetern
wie können sie das aushalten kommt es da
nicht zu Problemen
klar würde ich gerne ein bisschen mehr
Privatsphäre haben
das hier ist im Moment mein persönlicher
Raum
für Lena ist alles besser als in der
Ukraine in Kälte ohne Wasser unter
Beschuss zu sitzen
deshalb versuche ich eher die großen
Pluspunkte zu sehen als nach kleinen
Problemchen zu schauen werden
schon fünf Monate leben sie hier Lena
hofft dass sie bald eine Wohnung
bekommen und an Deutschkursen teilnehmen
können zumindest gibt es einen
Internetanschluss für viele hier die
einzige Verbindung zur Heimat
im Gegensatz zu Asylbewerbern dürfen
sich Ukrainer frei bewegen doch wohin
dafür sind die Kommunen zuständig bei
dem extrem engen Wohnungsmarkt in
Konstanz ist das eine gewaltige Aufgabe
dazu hat ein Konstanzer 2015 aus der Not
eine erfolgreiche Idee entwickelt till
Hastreiter Gründer der Initiative mit
dem Namen Raumteiler trifft sich mit
einer Vermieterin zur
Wohnungsbesichtigung
Raumteiler spürt privaten Wohnraum auf
und vermittelt ihn an Flüchtlinge
anfangs rein ehrenamtlich inzwischen in
Kooperation mit der Stadt Konstanz das
Erfolgsrezept Profile von Mietern und
Vermietern erstellen Übereinstimmungen
finden und sie zusammenbringen
die Wohnungsbesitzer bekommen das Geld
vom Jobcenter auf dem freien Markt
könnten sie oft bis zu 40% mehr Miete
bekommen warum verzichten Sie darauf
das war mir gar nie wichtig sondern
wichtig war mir Menschen zu kriegen die
jetzt wirklich dringend diesen Wohnraum
brauchen und mit denen ich auch gut
klarkomme kann eine Vermietung durch das
Projekt Raumteiler habe klare Vorteile
erklärt Hastreiter ich sag sogar
manchmal so ein bisschen überheblich wir
haben die besten Mieter in der Stadt im
normalen Mietmarkt gibt es ja immer die
Unsicherheit funktioniert das oder
funktioniert es nicht und das wird bei
uns minimiert weil das Begleitete Mieter
sind wir begleiten die Mieter über
mehrere Monate in dieses wohnverhältnis
Sie als Vermieter müssen sich gar nicht
groß kümmern die Mitarbeiter des
raumteilerprojektes suchen brach
liegenden Wohnraum z.B zugerümpelte
Zimmer oder ungenutzten Platz im großen
Haus allein leben da Senioren rund 500
geflüchtete haben so schon ein neues zu
Hause gefunden
auch diese vierköpfige ukrainische
Familie hat durch Raumteiler eine
Unterkunft bekommen eine Zweitwohnung
die vorher oft leer stand Mutter Lilia
war zunächst nur mit den beiden Söhnen
geflohen und wurde von einer
Privatperson aufgenommen als ihr Mann
nachkam wurde es bei der Gastfamilie zu
eng und das Raumteiler Projekt hat Ihnen
diese Wohnung vermittelt
eigentlich ein wahrer Glückstreffer aber
Lilia muss immer wieder an die Heimat
denken
[Musik]
glauben sie dass sie zurückkehren können
nun ja wir sind aus der Stadt Lissy
chansk das ist im Osten der Ukraine das
ist jetzt besetztes Territorium das
heißt wir können nirgendwohin zurück
unsere Wohnung ist zerstört wir
versuchen es hier ich weiß nicht wie es
weitergeht Pläne für die Zukunft haben
wir nicht
die eigenen vier Wände helfen Lilia
schon manchmal das Heimweh zu vergessen
solange ihr Mann und sie nicht arbeiten
zahlt der Staat das Wohngeld
Migrationsforscher Gerald Knaus
appelliert an die Politik auch die
unbürokratisch zu unterstützen die
Flüchtlinge bei sich zu Hause aufnehmen
wie es schon in einigen europäischen
Ländern passiert irische Haushalte
bekommen wenn sie Ukraine aufnehmen
800 Euro im Monat
das ist kein Almosen das ist kein
auslagern der Verantwortung das ist eine
Anerkennung dass die private Aufnahme
der Schlüssel ist zum Erfolg sonst wird
eine solch große Krise nur sehr schwer
zu bewältigen sein in Deutschland ist
noch nicht einheitlich geregelt wie
private Gastfamilien unterstützt werden
eine pauschale ohne bürokratische Hürden
könnte es Ihnen leichter machen denn
klar ist wohnen ist der erste Schritt
zur Integration
[Musik]
Essen Metropole im Ruhrgebiet hier hat
man Erfahrung mit Integration seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg wurden in der Region
Millionen Zuwanderer aus aller Welt
aufgenommen
so möchte sie genannt werden ist eine
von ihnen vor fünf Jahren hat Iranerin
in Deutschland Asyl erhalten besonders
wichtig war ihr möglichst wieder
arbeiten zu können in ihrem Job als
Bademeisterin
ich bin gekommen in Deutschland
hat eine große Wunsche noch mal in meine
Jobs laufen deswegen ich habe Erfahrung
aber kann ich nicht gut ich sprechen
deutsch aber diese Job echt ich spielen
mit meine Herz
seit dem Sommer arbeitet Pariser in
diesem städtischen Schwimmbad geholfen
hat ihr dabei Uwe Ringelberg er
unterstützt im Auftrag der Stadt Essen
Flüchtlinge bei der Jobsuche sind sie
stolz wenn sie ihren Schützling sollen
Aktion sehen
ja kann man nicht anders sagen wir sind
gelungenes Beispiel für Integration es
ist hier in Essen einfacher für
geflüchtete Fuß zu fassen also woanders
in Deutschland ich glaube ja wegen der
Betriebe hier und die Aufgeschlossenheit
der Menschen im Ruhrgebiet sowieso und
im Essen im Besonderen weil das ist
gelernt hier hier gibt's schon seit ganz
langer Zeit zugezogen
viele Arbeitgeber in Essen haben selbst
eine Migrationsgeschichte das macht
Flüchtlingen das finden eine Arbeit
leichter
Pariser hatte bereits im Iran als
Bademeisterin gearbeitet musste hier nur
noch den Rettungsschwimmer machen das
Schwimmbad war froh eine engagierte
Mitarbeiterin zu gewinnen denn
Schwimmmeister sind Mangelware einziger
Schwachpunkt die Sprache
Arbeitsvermittlung Sprachkurse
wohnraumfinanzieren mit 20% mehr
geflüchteten als im Vorjahr bedeutet das
für die Stadt Essen auch mehr Ausgaben
erzählt uns der Oberbürgermeister geben
Sie jetzt mehr aus für Integration mit
mehrflüchtlingen als in vergangenen
Jahren
7000 Menschen aufgenommen in Essen die
Leistung gewähren wir wir unterstützen
Sie wir haben unsere Infrastruktur
ausgerichtet und es ist nicht nur um
mehr sondern es geht auch um Prioritäten
setzen das heißt die eine oder andere
Aufgabe aktuell der Stadtverwaltung
bleibt liegen weil wir uns genau um
diese Menschen kümmern wollen und auch
müssen
in diesem Essener Unternehmen hat das
Tradition geflüchteten helfen in ihrer
neuen Heimat anzukommen schon seit
Jahrzehnten
im firmeneigenen Ringerverein trainieren
viele Jugendliche mit
Migrationshintergrund darunter auch 14
Ukraine
auf der Matte gibt es keinen du bist
wusste du bist Ukraine du bist deutscher
sondern hier ist jeder gleich und hier
lernen die Kinder auch teilweise wenn
man die deutsche Sprache indem sie sich
mit den Kindern auf Deutsch unterhalten
kleines Beispiel dazu habe ich nur
kleines Kind hat innerhalb von 9 Monaten
auf einmal fließen Deutsch sprechen
können
der 17-Jährige Musa malikow aus Kiew
nimmt dafür lange Anfahrtswege in Kauf
anderthalb Stunden mit Bus und Bahn
viermal die Woche
am Anfang war es sehr schwer aber hier
beim Ring habe ich mit der Zeit viele
Freunde gefunden ich bekomme hier große
Unterstützung und Freundschaft
das Ringen im Verein organisiert von
einem Unternehmer der verstanden hat
Integration tut seiner Firma gut viele
die hier auf der Matte standen arbeiten
inzwischen als Schweißer
Elektroingenieure und sogar als
Montageleiter im kranbauunternehmen von
Ralf Teichmann es wäre viel zu schade
wenn wir die in Hartz IV und
Arbeitslosigkeit hängen lassen würden
alle sind glücklich und hochmotiviert
dass Sie bei uns zum Beispiel die Chance
bekommen arbeiten zu können ihren ihr
eigenes Einkommen zu verdienen und ich
dem Staat auf der Tasche hängen wollen
eine gute Möglichkeit Stellen neu zu
besetzen denn auf dem ausgedünnten
Arbeitsmarkt wird das immer schwieriger
Zuwanderung als Chance so sehen das
viele Arbeitgeber im Ruhrgebiet Essen
zeigt dass beide Seiten voneinander
profitieren können geflüchtete und die
Gesellschaft die sie aufnimmt
im sächsischen Pirna ist unter großen
Schwierigkeiten etwas gelungen was viele
nicht erwartet hätten das Misstrauen
gegenüber Fremden wurde im Laufe der
Zeit abgebaut das ist vor allem dem
Engagement einzelner zu verdanken
seit 2010 sitzt der parteilose
Oberbürgermeister Klaus-peter Hanke im
Rathaus
2015 wurde Perner Tatort von
Rechtsextremen Übergriffen
Oberbürgermeister Hanke bekam anonyme
Drohungen ließ sich aber nicht vom Kurs
abbringen und hielt an der Unterbringung
von Flüchtlingen fest
was macht das mit einem oder haben sie
auch mal überlegt den Job hinzuschmeißen
ja sicherlich beeinträchtigt ein dass
dann persönlich ich hatte ja dann auch
Polizeischutz erhalten aber am Ende muss
man seine Aufgabe wahrnehmen der
Oberbürgermeister bringt Einheimische
und Flüchtlinge in Gesprächsrunden
zusammen sorgt für Sprachkurse und
Unterbringung in den leerstehenden
Plattenbauwohnungen und er hat sogar
eine eigene Stelle im Rathaus geschaffen
die sich ausschließlich um die
Vernetzung aller flüchtlingsinitiativen
in Pirna kümmert nach acht Jahren
unerschrockenen Engagements hat sich die
Lage geändert ich denke am Ende ist es
uns hier gelungen mit der gesamten
Stadtgesellschaft Aufklärung zu schaffen
um dann diese Vorfälle hier in pirmasen
mehr stattfinden zu lassen
heute begrüßt der Oberbürgermeister den
Teilnehmer eines Integrationskurses
durch persönlichen Kontakt will Hanke
dazu beitragen die Scheu der Ausländer
gegenüber Behörden abzubauen
er verteilt sogar seine Visitenkarten
damit die Neuankömmlinge sich bei
Problemen direkt bei ihm melden können
inzwischen gibt es in Pirna 14
Initiativen für Integrationsarbeit
städtische kirchliche und auch private
ein gutes Beispiel für das Miteinander
ist die Tafel hier arbeiten sie alle
zusammen deutsche geflüchtete und
Asylbewerber während die meisten Tafeln
große Probleme haben genügend
Lebensmittel zu bekommen kann sich
Sandra vorka die Leiterin der Tafel in
Pirna über viele Spenden freuen ist
diese Auswahl jeden Tag da so wie wir
Ausgabe
es reicht
für jeden Tafelkunden vom ersten bis zum
letzten
die tafelleiterin sorgt für gute
Teamarbeit egal woher die Mitarbeiter
kommen Ali aus dem Irak sucht seit zwei
Jahren Arbeit so lange er keine hat
hilft er hier gerne mit
ich liebe Arbeit hier auch Samstag und
Sonntag keine Problem hier auch nicht
kommen
zu Hause ich bin alleine was mache ich
einen ganz anderen Hintergrund hat Frank
er ist in Pirna aufgewachsen und war
seit der Kindheit in der rechten Szene
früher auch 2015 schrie er
ausländerfeindliche Parolen jetzt
arbeitete gerne in der gemischten Runde
sein Anfang hier vor sechs Jahren war
nicht freiwillig ich bin damals durch
Arbeitsstunden hierher gekommen vom
Gericht wegen Volksverhetzung ich habe
meine Meinung total geändert zurzeit
also ich verstehe es dass
deutsche die Ausländer Hilfe brauchen
ich habe total damals falsch gehandelt
in dem Moment
habt ihr auch Freundschaften geschlossen
ja klar also ich verstehe mich mit Alex
ja super also es ist super Kollege
[Gelächter]
super Kollege
es warten deutsche wie Flüchtlinge
gemeinsam auf die Ausgabe an die 200
Haushalte mit bis zu 12 Personen
bekommen hier jede Woche ihre
Lebensmittel
tafelleiterin Sandra Burkhardt achtet
rigoros darauf dass hier keine
ausländerfeindliche Stimmung aufkommt
wenn es jetzt hier so ein bisschen
Anfeindungen gibt untereinander was tun
sie dann paar Sekunden Kollegen alles
für seine Familie eine große Familie
mitspielt das tut mir leid da müssen wir
uns dran
irgendwo denkt er muss seine Meinung
hier drin äußern auf das rechtsradikal
ist oder außer fand es egal wie gibt's
ja nicht wir sind alle gleich und wir
leben einfach füreinander und das ist
wichtig
Pirna zeigt dass das große Engagement
vieler einzelner hilft Vorurteile und
gegenseitiges Misstrauen abzubauen wie
sieht es im Rest des Landes aus zum
Jahresende warnten Politiker und
Verantwortliche vor einem
Stimmungsumschwung in der Bevölkerung
eine repräsentative Umfrage im Auftrag
des ZDF zeigt ein anderes Bild
auf die Frage zur Zeit kommen viele
Flüchtlinge aus Krisengebieten zu uns
nach Deutschland was meinen Sie sagen
55% Deutschland kann das verkraften wie
schon im flüchtlingsjahr 2016 40%
glauben das nicht damals waren es 44%
klar ist der historische
Flüchtlingszustrom aus der Ukraine und
anderen Ländern ist ein weiterer
Härtetest viele haben seit 2015
dazugelernt sind besser vorbereitet
andernorts müssen endlich Strukturen
verändert werden damit der Kraftakt
nicht zur Zerreißprobe wird
[Musik]